- Today is all about
music and my band y'all.
As we unveil moments from the show
we've never aired until now.
Something particularly special
happens on this stage when we have
musicians of all different backgrounds.
And it led to some
fascinating conversations
when we had Michael Bublé
and Randy Jackson here.
Jason even got a shout out, take a look.
- Okay, I'll get my friend, Jess Collins
to help me over there.
The beautiful talented Jess.
- Jess Collins!
Jesse Collins everybody.
- Don't listen.
There's a lot of shows on TV Michael,
but this is the best band,
I'm telling you these guys are incredible.
- Yeah!
- Well, this is your touring band, right?
- So wait no, you don't know this.
I don't know if everybody knows this,
but the reason why okay.
The reason why, this is not a lie.
I'm not being nice okay.
It's just true.
My career exists.
The reason why I have
had longevity is the man
behind that keyboard right there,
his name is Jason Halbert.
- Jason's a bad boy.
- And wait, wait.
And this is the best part.
Jason actually was hired by
Randy Jackson to be in my band.
- Wow, really?
And I when I won idol -
Yes, actually he hired for
Justin, but I stole him.
- Oh, Seriously?
- But we're a Texan Justin
don't know what feelings.
- Exactly.
Yeah. But no then he
hired him to do my show
and that's how our relationship started,
because of Randy.
- Really, isn't amazing
to look back at your life
and to have that, it's so cool.
- Yeah.
I'm telling you,
you need those partners in life though,
that really, he is my musical partner.
- You wanna hear something weird?
Yesterday I got up because
I knew I was gonna come
and do promo for this record.
And I always get anxious and nervous.
- Yeah.
And what I do every time is,
I make myself practice telling
myself what I'm grateful for.
And I start calling all of
those people in my life.
- Oh.
- That have been there
with me all that time.
- Brilliant.
It gets me into that
place where I can come,
and look how happy I am on this couch.
- Gratitude, gratitude.
Honestly, I forget this is a TV show.
- All these bright colors.
I'm so cozy with you guys.
I feel like I could,
can I come back again?
- Yes, same panel.
- Should we play poker or something?
- Should we?
I love poker!
I just bought a poker table
from my ranch in Montana.
- Whoa.
- Are you gonna come visit me?
- I'll come to Montana.
- It's cold as, as hell, but it's fun.
- Oh, cold as hell but it's fun?
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Sounds like Ireland.
- I'll put a heater that
- I like Ireland too.
- Poker on the ice rink.
- Still filming that tune you
named in Ireland, in Dublin.
- You film in Dublin?
- We filmed this season in Dublin.
The last season was in
Australia because of COVID.
- Wow, I love Ireland.
- But, it was cold, but it was fun though.
- Yeah. Irish people.
I love, I'm like 25% Irish.
- They're great. They're the great.
- Yeah. I might be 2%.
I don't know, I gotta check.
- Alright, once again
I'd like to thank Randy
for connecting me with Jason.
He's my musical partner.
I love him so much.